there are times when the data isn't
available
and you need to collect your own now
when talking about the various methods
that can be used
there are a few factors that distinguish
them
for instance there's the level of
intervention
is it observational which is strictly
hands-off or is it experimental
where you get in the mix and you create
a situation
what kind of data type do you have is it
quantitative or numerical data which
is what we often use in data science or
is it qualitative specifically text
which can be analyzed but requires
different approaches
and how about the location is it online
or is it in person all of these
combinations can be used to gather data
that you need
if you're careful about your design for
instance
let's look at interviews these are ideal
for new topics or audiences
they can be structured or unstructured
however
interviews are generally very time
consuming and they may require a very
specialized training
this is one of the situations where you
actually may want to hire an
anthropologist or a sociologist to come
in and conduct the research for you
next surveys they can be open-ended or
closed-ended
they're very easy to administer online
to a lot of people
but you need to watch out for wording
and sampling bias in order to get the
information that's going to be really
most useful in helping you reach your
goals in your project
next is card sorting this is where
participants sort topics that are
written on different cards
card sorting is useful for determining
categories and hierarchies
it's also a great way to check the
usability of a website
you can actually do different kinds of
card sorting in terms of an exploratory
one to find out how you should do it
and another kind to see how well your
proposed solution works
next how about experiments this is where
you have a manipulation
that's where you get involved and you
cause a situation to be different for
one group of people or another
some people freak out about the word
manipulation and think it's about
coercion or mind control
it simply means about creating different
conditions
and it is generally considered the best
method for cause and effect inferences
on the other hand in most situations
experimentation can be labor intensive
and can require very extensive
specialized training
there is one major exception to this and
that's a b testing
which is used on web pages where you
have two versions of a web page or an
element on a web page
and it's randomly assigned one version
or another to viewers
in summary to start a data science
project you'll first get exactly the
data that you need
if what it doesn't exist you will have
to collect the new data
many of these methods may require
in-depth training and you may want to
hire consultants for them
also there are important ethical issues
when conducting research
especially when it's live and in person
you'll want to consult an expert about
those